thank you Jim and thank you David
for inviting me to this david simon as
many of you know is one of the leading
scholars in this field and it's when i
saw the invitation i really wanted to
respond every year at the UN the
commemoration the genocide is marked
usually in some combination of ceremony
and substance but i think it's quite an
important day for the organization
reflecting on some of its less
propitious times and some of the times
were saying why was it so inactive and
why you did so many people seem to be
looking in other ways even when they
were looking at the same conflict but
not looking for the genocide I would try
to be fairly quick I wanted to say a
couple words about the recommendations
from the independent inquiry in 1999
headed by hang of our Carlson a former
prime minister of Sweden looking at the
UN's action or as I say in action in the
case of Rwanda and what has happened in
those particular areas since that time
and then just say a few words about the
responsibility to protect and how I
think it is or isn't doing at this point
the independent inquiry was something
that wasn't requested by the General
Assembly it was not requested by the
Human Rights Council it was not
requested by the Security Council it was
something that secretary general kofi
annan at that point felt needed to be
done and I think was something very very
personal for him because he was the
undersecretary general in charge of
peacekeeping operations at the time and
he has sent sent if you look at the
history a number of cables at that point
telling romeo Dallaire the commander
sorted to cool it and watch him very
carefully the mandate given by the
Security Council which was rather narrow
and not expanded too much I think it's
something that's lived with them to this
day and so he decided on his own that
there ought to be an independent inquiry
into this and I think everyone since I
know his successor Ban ki-moon from the
very beginning did not want
this on his watch he did not want any
genocides on his watch and was something
that he carried with them as as part of
this legacy and that's why the UN
champion responsibility protect and
that's why I ended up doing a lot of
work with him for a number of a number
of years the the ended independent
inquiry is worth reading if nothing else
to see sort of the inside story of what
didn't happen and why all those Samantha
power many other people have written
very very eloquently on this but they
had three recommendations that sort of
like to focus on first the first was
that the UN needed a system-wide
strategic approach to genocide and
genocide prevention it simply didn't
exist at that point even the High
Commissioner for Human Rights was a
relatively recent innovation at that
point and not well integrated into the
system as a whole and when people looked
at Rwanda they looked at you know me or
the UN peacekeeping operation they
looked at the effort to implement the
Arusha Accords they looked at it as one
more civil war situation that had to be
dealt with in fairly standard terms of
mediation and cease fires and zones and
separation of forces and one thing or
another and through even into the really
some of the most intense part of the of
the crimes there is still this tendency
to say well okay what permission has the
Security Council given us what kind of
leeway do we have what is this little
operation you Namir allowed to do and a
real effort on the part of many member
states the u.s. included and pushed very
much by belgium in particular to say
let's pull it out because it can no
longer do the sort of peacekeeping
mission that it was set up to do the
neither party is really respecting the
Russia Accords and so the focus really
was very much on peacekeeping not on the
nasty business of atrocity crimes and
that mindset was very very difficult for
the organization so
I think one of the lessons that people
did draw from this was that you needed
to have genocide prevention and then
eventually responsibility to protect at
the table and they're talking about
options in a particular position I often
say you're not going to get the right
answers if you don't right if you don't
ask the right questions and people
weren't asking the right questions in
Rwanda because whatever is happening the
streets whatever was just sort of
messing up their paradigm of what this
was all about and so I think that very
much the genocide been led to the
creation of the post of the special
adviser on the prevention of genocide
that originally was the post it was
part-time and at the assistant secretary
general level and then later when Ban
ki-moon came in he said no it should be
full time and it should be elevated to
the position of undersecretary general
but in the meantime the responsibility
to protect came along and I'll talk
about that more later but the decision
was you should have two special advisers
a joint office one focus just on
genocide the other focused on a wider
range of atrocity crimes including not
only genocide but war crimes ethnic
cleansing and crimes against humanity
that those may be in fact be precursors
the genocide and in fact through the
years Frances ding was the special
adviser for the prevention of genocide
and we work together for many many years
and we must have looked at 50 or 60
different situations around the world
some of them of course came up week
after week after week a new analysis
other sort of came and went with crises
we never saw what I've of us really
thought was genocide we saw a lot of
crimes against humanity we saw a fair
number of war crimes we saw a few cases
of ethnic cleansing but nothing that
looked like true genocide and the Rwanda
standard in terms of the immensity of
the killings and how targeted they were
sort of left in one's mind even though
genocide doesn't have to be hundreds of
thousands but it left this perception
that this is a very very
broad and deep crime the second
recommendation I wanted to 2.2 is they
talked about the UN needing an early
warning system and i think it was
somewhat false understanding but people
thought you know officials just didn't
know what was going on and if they had
early warning somehow they would have
had that headed this off but that would
have made all the difference I don't
think that's actually true I think
people had some idea at least of what
was going on and it was more a question
of assessment and understanding an
analysis rather than simply hearing that
there is a lot of violence going on but
nevertheless that became part of the law
in the UN and in the early part of the
century a great deal of effort on early
warning systems and then when the summit
happened in 2005 the world summit and
they adopted the responsibility to
protect one of the first recommendations
in it wasn't recommendation was a
decision by all the heads of state and
government was that all the member
states should assist the UN in
developing a better early warning
capacity and that's been sort of ongoing
I argued and I think it's in some of the
Secretary General's reports we did one
on early warning an assessment but
really it's that assessment piece that
is really the critical part of it
actually understanding what you're
seeing following dynamics in which a
society is going through a not taking
sort of isolated snapshots which early
warning and somebody sort of implies now
there's a new twist on it now which
could be important so far it's mostly
rhetoric but just in recent months the
UN has adopted and Secretary General's
become a very big advocate of the idea
of Rights up front and that didn't come
only from the experience in Rwanda feben
Itza it also came in many ways from Sri
Lanka and really rather searing
experience in Sri Lanka that you needed
rights and you need it as the most
egregious rights violations atrocity
crimes right up front and you're
thinking I recall actually the only time
I was over shut out of a meeting of the
policy committee the top group the
Secretary General
together in policy was when it was Sri
Lanka because people just didn't want
that r2p perspective they just didn't
want to focus on atrocity crimes and the
humanitarians were dominating the
discussion internally and that
discussion was all about humanitarian
access and all about humanitarian space
so if you're going to tell the
government that we think you're on the
verge or beginning to commit atrocities
that might close down some of the doors
and the communication so the
humanitarians didn't want us
troublemakers at the table and I think
now they sort of regret that so writes
up front is a new approach now the third
thing that they recommended and it's
rather a long part of the report was
really a renovation of peacekeeping
because many ways they looked at you
Namir this little force there and looked
at this is a failure of you Namir and a
failure of the Security Council not to
give you nemore the right kind of the
right kind of authority and right kind
of a mandate and I do think we have seen
in peacekeeping a considerable evolution
from that time at that point there was a
sense that peacekeepers basically had a
set of instructions if citizens
civilians were being killed beyond their
immediate perimeter that was unfortunate
but they were not to extend themselves
in Rwanda some peacekeepers did extend
themselves I think of the Ghanaians in
particular and many many lives were
saved but on the whole the mission was
not nearly as assertive as it might have
been and the initially the Security
Council reduced the size of the mission
when the violence started but you look
at more robust peacekeeping now and it's
becoming quite common most recently you
look at the Central African Republic
it's a little late but it is more
assertive chapter 7 mandate the same in
Mali the same in the eastern DRC and
you're seeing some results from each of
these even in Somalia which was on the
agenda for ever and ever and ever there
was significant ammu
towards a more assertive kind of force
so it's making some difference now on
the responsibility to protect at the
time of the genocide now you had
basically a school of thought about
humanitarian intervention it was pushed
by bernard crucian air and some others
seen as something of a french concept
but it was something of an all or
nothing if you see these kinds of crimes
breaking out even if you have to cross a
border and the government is the culprit
sovereignty shouldn't stop you you
should have every right in fact of duty
and obligation to intervene and
intervene militarily that obviously was
not terribly popular with most the
member states especially small ones that
they were worried about their
sovereignty I was not at all popular in
Washington either as jimmer may or may
not comment he talks about capitals but
that was sort of the paradigm in which
people looked at what you do in a
humanitarian emergency and because was
all nothing the answer was usually
nothing a little after the genocide in
Rwanda of Francis ting and some others
at Brookings Roberto Cohen and some
others developed this idea as
sovereignty as responsibility that part
of sovereignty is having responsibility
to protect your populations not just
citizens but the populations on your
territory after Rwanda and then after
seven Itza coffee and on then encouraged
a creation of an independent commission
largely canadian funded headed by
muhammad saw moon former foreign
minister of algeria and Gareth Evans a
former Foreign Minister of Australia and
they were looking at the problem of
sovereignty and international
intervention so it was sort of the old
paradigm we sovereignty as the problem
intervention is the solution what could
you do sort of to bend sovereignty a
little bit and they came up with this
idea of responsibility to protect in
many ways it was like Frances dings
earlier idea on sovereignty as
responsibility but it was finally
accepted at the World Summit 2005 and
then when Ban ki-moon came in it was a
first effort to action
create a living breathing doctrine
institutional form and actually apply it
operationally and I have the good
fortune be able to try to do that and I
think it's important to think of the
three pillars within r2p because they're
all very relevant to what happened in
Rwanda the first pillar is state
responsibility all the heads of state
and government agreed that they would
protect populations not just citizens
but all the populations on their
territory by preventing genocide war
crimes ethnic cleansing crimes against
humanity as well as their incitement and
incitement peace was very important
operationally because in cycling is
often a big part of the problem as it
had been in Rwanda but there's a second
pillar and these pillars all to be
enacted simultaneously and out
sequentially that there is an obligation
by the larger international community to
assist the state and the society in
terms of preventing these kinds of
crimes and there we didn't see really
any significant international action
other than some NGO efforts and a few
human rights efforts to try to work with
the people Rwanda before the genocide to
try to build the kinds of barriers that
would make this kind of violence less
likely but that second pillar is
enormously enormously important it has
to do with development aid it has to do
with what kinds of institutions you're
trying to build what kinds of
legislation what you're doing with
international human rights and other
agreements and it can be very much a in
some ways an invasion of sovereignty in
an early way to try to go in and help
societies reshape themselves and the
third pillar then is a response pillar
but it isn't necessarily just military
it might be as it was in Libya but it
could maybe many many other ways
including sanctions including diplomatic
and including some very quiet quiet
efforts and let me just say worded to
about the track record today and then
turn it over to Jim Trowell to talk
about capitals I think we applied
responsibility protecting the years I
was in the UN probably to 10 or 12
different situations
most of those got zero publicity and
they were not supposed to get publicity
a few of them did get publicity most
people think of Libya because the
Security Council picked it up and
authorize the use of force and they
think of Syria as a case where it didn't
do that but I think there are many
others like Kyrgyzstan which looked like
ethnic cleansing which one was able to
intervene diplomatically and quietly
along with the OSCE the High
Commissioner for national minorities to
help discourage violence their guinea
was another case in point ghana twice
was the first time applied in 2008
before we even had the first speech even
on r2p hadn't been given but it looked
like a time for prevention it looked
like ethnic cleansing and we were very
much worried about Rwanda all over again
so both coffee and on and his mediation
on behalf of the AU and the Secretary
General Ban ki-moon when he went both to
the AU summit natus and and to Kenya
itself the same message was given to
both the leaders of the opposition and
the president that your people are
inciting what could very well be drastic
crimes accountability has to be upheld
and you could be liable and this has to
cease and desist and the incitement
stopped it wasn't the only reason the
violent stop but I had something to do
with it and again it was a question of
coordinating the AU message and the UN
message there were a number of other
cases I think Cote d'Ivoire where r2p
was very relevant was some use of force
at the end but I think it made some
difference and a number of other cases
that are probably little a little
quieter obviously we had major failures
the eastern DRC it's working a little
better now but when i was there was not
working terribly well somalia wasn't
going terribly well and obviously syria
in which i spent so much time the
concern was there the intention was
there the tools never were there to move
it forward and obviously a Soviet
Chinese vetoes to Russian Chinese vetoes
and do anything to help
so looking at this it seems to me there
is another site here just mentioned in
passing the question of the individual
responsibility to protect I think it's
very very relevant to Rwanda I think
it's relevant to allow these other cases
if the responsibility to protect is only
seen as outside intervention as external
action it's going to fail probably more
often than it's going to succeed most
places where he had success it was
because there are internal forces
internal dynamics civil society one sort
of another that in fact gave you
something to build on and that r2p
should be seen as a bottom-up exercise
and not just as a top-down my wife is a
psychologist and we're working on this
together to try to develop the question
of the individual responsibility it's
not enough for people in the society
site where things went terribly wrong
why didn't someone save us its first and
foremost responsibility lies within that
society and I think that has to be
recognized but it sometimes take some
nourishment from from the outside now
the question I guess we all have to ask
if the same events of late nineteen
ninety-three and early nineteen
ninety-four were to happen in the wand
again with the reaction internationally
be any different I was there at one
point in 38th floor just coincidentally
that the for the Secretary General is on
on the day when the Belgians were saying
they were throwing their troops which
really undermined the mission I remember
the atmosphere there and i was there
from an NGO you and IA USA but the
feeling that there was just no choice
the big powers didn't want the mission
some of the non permanent members of the
Security Council did and the Belgians a
former colonial power and the backbone
of the force said no matter what they're
pulling their forces out and a sense of
resignation and there was a sense of a
different legacy the legacy from
Mogadishu and Black Hawk Down and the
movement in Congress to pro forces back
and secretary and the president clinton
in his decision to make very very
restrictive the times that US would
commit forces to peacekeeping the
atmosphere is just as negative as could
be so i think yes there's a lot more
machinery in place i think there's an
international standards concerned partly
because of r2p much much more prevalent
and higher visibility than before but in
the end of the day things really get
nasty is the Security Council going to
act and are the big power is willing to
get involved that I think remains
sixty-four-thousand-dollar question and
that's the one that I know Jim trough is
not going to answer for us but thank you